welcome everyone to my first game recap
from kregero chess uh just finished
round one I was playing an opponent by
the name of Andreas tenold rated just
over 2000. and before this game pairings
went up less than an hour before so I
didn't really have too much time to
prepare but I did find a good handful of
my point schemes I actually found his
leechas account as well and I noticed
that my opponent likes to play the Timon
of Sicilian which is actually an opening
that I like to play as black so I
decided to play E4 in this game going
into a taimanov which we did get after
takes takes Knight C6 Knight C3 Queen C7
this is kind of the starting position of
taimanov and here I opted for a really
rare and tricky line and I'll just go
ahead and show in the database I played
the six most popular move here Queen to
D3 now this is a line that I don't think
I've ever played
for at least in a tournaments maybe I
play that online but the idea is really
interesting and at first this move looks
very dumb and counter-intuitive because
White's blocking the bishop and just
bringing the queen out early but the
idea in in many lines is to play Queen
G3 and challenge The Black Queen on C7
and we're going to see how this plays
out so my point playing that six which
is one of like the main moves I played
Knight dp5 harassing The Black Queen I
mean drops back to B8 and now I play
Queen G3 and not only am I challenging a
queen but I'm also threatening the fork
on C7 so black has to be really careful
here and black trades Queens then I'm
very happy to get these double pawns
with apple open file and I'm still
threatening Knight C7 and this is
actually already very good for white
so instead my opponent played Pawn to D6
which was still kind of the main line of
my preparation and I went ahead and
played Bishop to E3 just preparing to
get the Rook to D1 and pressure the
d-pawn even more
and here my opponent took a very long
time before playing Pawn to A6 and I'm
pretty sure my opponent
um of course was out of his preparation
it's actually taking time many moves
after Queen D3 but I think he took a
long time on A6 specifically because
there is a scary looking move for whites
which did occur to me during the game so
move Bishop to B6
and after Pawn takes B5 Knight takes B5
um
it's an interesting peace sacrifice
because White's threatening Bishop C7
and it's not entirely clear how black
comes out alive now I didn't go for this
because I was still in my preparation
after Pioneer 6 and I knew the top
engine move but I am curious if we
checked the engine here is this at all
playable for whites no it's not because
Knight takes E4 Queen wow Queen H4 Rook
A4
and the Knights defended the Queen's not
getting trapped I actually didn't see
this during the game it's a really cool
resource for black
um so yeah instead of going into
complete dubiousness
um I played the the standard move here
top engine move Knight D4
and it looks like White's wasted a
little bit of time moving the Knight
back and forth
but blocks also spent a move playing
Queen B8 which is not the most useful
and from this position uh my opponent
played Bishop to D7 and I will say that
I was uh prepared for Pawn H5 in the
game
and before the game I looked at one line
specifically which was H5 F3 Bishop D7
queenside Castle B5 takes takes and
queen F2 and this position was on my
computer about 10 minutes before the
game
so interesting enough
what happened in our game my opponent
played Bishop D7 first and I was trying
to figure out the differences between
what I looked at before and this line
but we actually ended up transposing
because I play F3 my opponent played B5
I took took now it's important to
understand here that if I
let's say a castle Queen side then B4
would Chase my knight back and block in
the bishop so it's important to start
with Bishop D3 just so that I can come
back to E2 and not block the bishop and
then my opponent plays H5 and I was
happy to see this move because I quickly
castle and I knew that uh the engine
gives white a small edge here but more
importantly I thought this position is
just a bit easier for white to play
because
blocks committed to H5 so it's not
likely black will safely be able to
Castle on the king side and also the
bishop is tied down to G7 the queen
actually serves a really nice purpose on
G3 pressuring G7 and D6 and it's not so
clear what black is supposed to do here
and we're going to see very quickly
um how uh things just snowballed in in
my favor
now I think what black probably should
have done during the game was Place
something like Knight D7 and maneuver
the night uh C5 or E5
um but what was played was Pawn H4 which
I think is still okay uh hitting the
queen provoking Queen F2
um and then here my opponent played a
very self-destructive move let me hide
the notation just to avoid spoilers but
uh thing to understand in this position
is it's white who really wants to open
the center because the king is on E8 and
I'm already castled and um yeah here my
opponent played Pawn D5
really just helping me achieve the goal
of opening the position and I'm pretty
sure my home played this move because
maybe he realized things are difficult
and sometimes the tendency is to try and
trade down when you feel under pressure
just to try and simplify and I'm sure he
calculated takes takes but he actually
told me after the game that he missed my
next move in this position and the next
move for white I think once you see it
you'll realize like it's very strong I
played this out pretty quickly but feel
free to pause the video if you want to
try and find the strong move here for
whites that my opponent overlooked the
move is Bishop to E4 creating a
situation black is under a lot of pain
because now the Knight is pinned uh
Bishop's not defended on C6 so taking
either minor piece runs into Bishop
takes C6 with check and meanwhile the
knights also attacked three times so the
position is already like really really
nice for y
and Spark you asked to do major damage
control
um but the game's not over because my
opponent uh still fights with Queen to
B7
I took we trade on D5
create a lot on D5 now we got a position
where black is severely behind
development King stolen Center and I
play a kind of nice multi-purpose move
here Bishop to G5
there's at least three purposes with
this move preventing block from castling
attacking the pawn and also just freeing
an e-file preparing Rook E1 with a
deadly check so things are very much in
White's favor but the game still
continues Pawn F6 was played and now I I
thought for a little bit here trying to
decide between Rook E1 check and Bishop
takes H4 ultimately I decided to take on
each four I was thinking if Rook E1 King
F7 and then after takes there's lines
where each two is a little bit tender
with the half open H file so I decided
just to take immediately and keep H2
battery defended now this does allow
black to Castle but then we went into a
line that actually calculated when I
played Bishop takes H4 so I dropped the
bishop back to G3 and after Bishop to D6
there's a pretty forcing sequence takes
takes and queen C5 check hitting the
king rook and also pressuring the pawn
so um I'm just trying to simplify
already up a pawn uh trying to win a
second Pawn after Queen C7 was played I
went ahead and took on D5 now I spent
some time before I took because
um there's a few options for black to
try and muddy the waters for one I
wasn't 100 sure about this end game
after takes takes King B7 even though it
lights up two pawns here there are ideas
for black to get counter play with
doubling and invading but I was thinking
I would play B4 here and just give the
square for the king and get the Rook
involved and this should be very
promising for whites but we didn't go
into that instead my opponent played
Rook C6 which is also kind of a scary
looking move creating the battery trying
to win the C2 Pawn
but also hitting a coupon so black is
winning back a pawn here however after
Queen F2 Rook takes H2 and then I play
Rook D1
um everything's under control I'm still
up up upon and the major factor in the
position is that the king uh on C8 is
far less safe than my king on C1
and from here the game continues Rook to
h8 Queen D2 creating the triple battery
uh preparing Rook D7 opponent plays Pawn
G5 trying to save the g-pawn
and here I wanted to play Rook D7
immediately but I wasn't sure about the
follow-up after Queen V6 so I decided to
start with Queen to D3 just keeping some
tracking possibilities open and here my
opponent played Rook H7 now I should
note my opponent was severely low on
time uh played this move with less than
30 seconds left so he was just living on
the 30 second increment
and
when I first saw this move I thought it
was just a media blunder like a game
losing blunder because white has Queen
F5 and if King B7 Rook D7 looks like it
just wins The Black Queen but I thought
a little bit more and realized it's not
so simple if I go for this line rookie
seven it's actually a really nice
counter shot for black your Rook takes
C2 and my queen is now overworked if I
take on C2 Rook takes D7 black is one
back the pawn and if King B1 there is
Rook C1 I believe I'm pretty sure black
is uh is okay here now I am tempted to
check with the engine I think I will go
ahead and just see uh is this
at all winning for whites no lock lock
equalizes with Rook C2 so it's good to
just be aware of
the opponent's counter tricks despite my
my time advantage and instead of going
into
that line I um very calmly play King to
B1 just getting the king off the C file
and now preparing Queen F5 and eventual
Rook D7 so I was trying to to just make
things really difficult for my opponents
and just create possibilities where
it'll be easy for my opponent to blunder
but the game still goes on King B7 was
played I play Queen F5 threatening Rook
D7 now
uh he plays King B6
I move back to D3 and after rookie seven
I found a nice way to just make progress
on the queen side looks like the king
should be exploitable but um I mean my
Rooks and queen are pretty much fully
optimized so the way to make progress
here is with a pawn break and the break
I went for is upon A4 uh not only making
Luft for my own King but just trying to
destabilize block structure and after
takes Queen D4 King B7 takes uh now the
king's just a bit more Airy and
um yeah we're gonna see how quickly this
goes downhill for Block after Queen B6 I
play Rook to D3 now I'm completely okay
leaving my back rank open
um not scared of the checks because I'm
just ready to play Rook B3 and Tuck the
king away on A2
and the game ended in a couple more
moves after King A7 Rook B3 Queen C7
um I think this is a final blunder but
it was already difficult for black I
played Queen to D4 check and my point
resigned here because if King ate then I
play Rook d8 and I'm winning the queen
uh the king is completely
boxed in in the corner
so this was the first game I think it
was relatively smooth
um it was a nice bit of opening
preparation especially to play a line
that I haven't played before got a nice
position and my opponent
um I think was just uncomfortable out of
the opening and just didn't handle
things correctly if there's one like big
Improvement for black it was probably
around here just choosing a different
plan
um H4 was already a bit overextending so
according to the engine black is still
fine after B4
82 yeah A5 and it's uh it's definitely a
flight from from this position
so anyway I hope people enjoyed this
recap
um stay tuned for the next game uh it's
6 12 so the next game starts in 48
minutes uh it's time to eat and prepare
and um yeah thanks for watching don't
forget to subscribe and I'll see you
guys in the next video